ari we have to talk about this wine
throwing moment i'm not going to marry
you guys i'm marrying binyam
wish through red wine in your face yeah
what were the thoughts that went through
your head i mean it was a total surprise
for me i see people are commenting on my
reaction and they're like why didn't you
get up and you know do something or that
was staged because no one would be that
calm if you didn't expect something and
it just like happened and also as i have
said before and i'll say again wine
really burns oh that bird is cute
so i got it in my eyes so i was like
okay and then for me it was like what
just happened and like shake it off and
then when i could see everything i was
like everyone kind of scattered so
bernie was like bam and then there was
like everyone left and i was like what
happened what did you do
was it hard for you not to retaliate
like did you have an urge to or no i
think i knew that the party was going to
be maybe a little bit a little bit
contentious like with me i'm just
dropping this bombshell which was not my
idea at all
to move there sorry that that might be
an issue but i just told myself before i
went and me and vinnie talked about it
and was like you know this is benny's
night like don't you know whatever
happens just you know be calm his last
day just you know let him enjoy and i
figure something might happen uh i
didn't expect that so i was just like
you know and it was just such a shock to
me that i would just i wasn't even
thinking i wasn't mad i wasn't like
upset i was like my white dress and
they're right
in my dress
oh my god i've never gotten alcohol to
the right place before that's a new
experience like you said this is a new
experience i've never heard a reaction
like that out of all the times i've seen
you know whine or whatever thrown in
someone's face i was like this is her
mom this is janice um positive optimus
coming out well i've been listening to a
lot of buddhist uh meditation stuff on
audible and just kind of like going
through this whole like getting older
and accepting oneself and all this stuff
so who knows maybe it's starting to rub
off where does your relationship with
wish stand now she doesn't want to talk
to me um and that's okay i think that
whatever issue
that they have first they need to work
stuff out with bitty but benny you sat
there with your mouth closed you didn't
say anything during the back and forth
what was going through your mind you
know she's she's my wife like so that
you like you look over here like with my
family like both of them i love them so
much i don't want to do something what's
going on like i didn't accept it just
like that like that
being always white even from like the
first time we were together because of
ethiopia like if you live together and
you have a baby and
you said that you wanted to move to the
u.s regardless if you were in love with
ari or not because you didn't want to
lose your family you wanted to be with
avi what do you say to fans who
are concerned that you really don't love
ari and you're just in the u.s for avi
yeah what do you say to fans
i love
but i don't love her but even if you
this relationship if it's working if it
is not working in the 90 days at least i
have to be for my son that's the number
one thing just have to be number one
that
i have to say just i love eric i don't
know who's happening with aries family
just still i don't know them and then
everybody come back here everything has
changed that's why just i want to see
what's going on like it is not working
in 990 days maybe i'll go back maybe
with my son
number unavailable because his phone is
off do you have any idea what's going on
no he literally just does not pick up
the phone all right at a point in time
you said that you felt as if you could
never trust binyam again has the trust
gotten better obviously bingham gave me
a lot of reasons not to trust him at
that time i'm not going to say that i
was wrong and not trusting him but at
the same time like i think what happened
is like when someone gives you a reason
not to trust them then you might like
run with it and then be like i couldn't
trust this person i can't trust anybody
so yeah
but in this case like i actually see a
change in vegan's behavior i see a
change in the relationship i'm getting
better about things and i think video is
getting better i told him the one thing
i always say don't turn up your phone
if you don't talk to me don't answer the
phone but don't turn it off for some
reason that always sets me off like i'm
very emotional so like if he turns his
phone off i'm like oh well now it's over
forever and like everything
like a black or white thinker like black
and white
oh my phone died and i'm like oh i was
worried for like five hours now that
binium is in the u.s i would think that
there there are more like temptations or
more it's a new experience for him so
have you run into any situations where
he might want to go out clubbing or
might want to go out and party you want
to answer this one yes
you should answer something
so definitely uh vinnie made me aware
before we got to the u.s like oh i want
to see everything i want to you know
like see what a club looks like and
i want to you know do all this stuff and
i'm like okay um you know i'm not a club
person so it's not even like something
where i'd be like oh like we could go
together and i'll show you like i'm just
like oh no so we'll see how that works
out but like he did get to experience
they went to las vegas i was not there
he stayed with friends and he you know i
don't know what happens at vegas stays
in vegas so you'll have to tell us did
you get to go to any clubs or do
anything
you know
how has it been to have binyam in the
house with your parents and how is that
dynamic then binium is everybody likes
him when they meet him you know he's
really charming and he's soft-spoken and
when he goes to someone's house like oh
can i help you with that like oh can i
clean this so it's hard not for prepared
really not to like him it's only you
that he gets trouble too what about if i
tell you back off she has to tell me she
is her own individual and she needs to
make that decision let's talk about
leandro is he still in the picture ari i
spoke to him what was it the other day
how is he doing unfortunately his
grandfather passed away so we've been
talking a lot the past like week or so
and um i was actually kind of close to
his you know family so that was
difficult you know i'm his friend so he
leans on me so binion gets to see that
you know just hard times i'm gonna be
there for my friend i know that opinion
is not a huge fan of it with that look
at that smile i don't know just every
time because he's there like you know
when
something is happening
over there like that's why just call me
like transform but i don't have a
problem with him it blew my mind that we
got the wine moment this soon this was
your first episode back so i just can't
help but wonder what is in store for the
rest of the season lots of drama some
really like victorious feelings like
some really like intense moments and you
know like family stuff and personal
stuff and even jealousy even you are
jealous of me okay um
basically it's going to be like if i had
to put our season in a genre i would say
like comedy drama dramady
yeah okay are we gonna see leandro again
is he gonna pop up i would like to see
the android oh yeah was there anything
you wanted or anything else you wanted
to say about my fitness app like mini
live okay wait tell us about it okay
yeah sure he's teaching dance style
workouts and like home workouts no noise
workouts even like sitting workouts and
um so like he's doing it on a website
but
him and his friend that's helping him
with that they're going to transition to
an app so i think it's really cool that
is cool so where can people learn more
about it
do they just need to follow you on
instagram
yeah so it's on the link in his
instagram bio it's beaniefit.co.co
congratulations
[Music]